[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday august 16th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
ever since apple rolled out its ios 14.5
last year making it easier for users to
restrict what data apps could collect
facebook has had a problem
the company and rivals like twitter and
snapchat have seen their ad revenue drop
that's because their ability to target
advertising to users has been hampered
by apple's decision to let users opt out
of having their online activity tracked
facebook and apple have been at odds
ever since
but the wall street journal has
exclusively learned that apple and
facebook back before it changed its name
to meta were once engaged in secret
conversations about a potential
partnership including revenue sharing
arrangements joining us to discuss what
the companies talked about and why it
didn't work out is our reporter salvador
rodriguez hi sal thanks for being here
yeah thank you so much for having me
so let's start with your reporting found
that this feud may be between apple and
facebook might not have come about what
kinds of things were the two companies
discussing before apple put in its
privacy policies with its ios 14.5 yeah
what we found in our reporting is that
before apple introduced ios 14 and and
really revolutionized the digital ad
industry
before all that came to be apple and
facebook had discussions over several
years about a number of different ways
that the two companies could work
together that would actually
give some of facebook's revenue over to
apple by way of the standard 30 cut that
apple takes from its app developers
that's according to people familiar with
the discussions
okay so what were the ways that apple
was trying to get at some of that
revenue yeah so basically this was all
happening during a time when apple was
really trying to ramp up its services
business and one way to do that was by
getting folks to add more in-app
purchases to their apps or
create features or business models that
included subscription revenue so we
understand that some of the suggestions
that were made were gifting for creators
but more notably
there was a talk of creating a
subscription-based ad-free facebook
the other thing that was also haggled
over between the two companies was over
a very specific facebook product called
boosted posts
there was some on the apple side who
argued that this product was not an
advertisement but rather an in-app
purchase
and if apple had ultimately decided that
it was an in-app purchase that would
have entitled the iphone maker to 30
of the revenue generated by facebook on
that particular product
what was facebook's reaction to these
proposals for example to having you know
boosting be considered an in-app
purchase or even to starting a
subscription service for facebook
from my reporting it's my understanding
that the
subscription-based facebook was
something that was
thought of but never really seriously
considered it just goes completely
against what facebook has always argued
it goes completely against their
advertising business when it comes to
boosted posts they were very steadfast
that that was an advertising product and
apple does not take advertising revenue
from the facebook side they argued that
even though this is something that you
can purchase through your smartphone a
lot of times these are small businesses
that are purchasing ads in this manner
it might be a food truck owner
who isn't really running their business
out of a laptop but still needs to
advertise and doing it through their
smartphone just makes the most sense for
that particular advertiser
they also argue that just like with
other ads in their system when you place
this ad you have to determine how many
people you would like to see this ad for
how long and it even goes into the
bidding system so it's competing against
other ads so they argued and held firm
that boosted posts are advertisements
they are not in-app purchases okay so
facebook didn't bite on those offers but
has apple had these kinds of
conversations maybe these proposals to
other companies apart from facebook well
that's the big question that's certainly
um what a lot of people are wondering
about
we do know that apple has a deal in
place with google that makes google the
default search engine
for the safari browser on
the iphone
and it's something where google pays
apple billions of dollars annually to
hold that ground
and after our story went out we heard
from at least one developer
who said that they found themselves in a
similar situation as facebook
with a boosted post feature of their own
and in that particular case their app
was rejected until they implemented that
feature as an in-app purchase and gave
apple the 30 percent cut
one of the companies said in response to
your reporting what have you heard from
apple and from facebook facebook didn't
contest our findings especially in
regards to their relationship with apple
and apple meanwhile what they had to say
is that they have these type of
conversations with
all sorts of developers all the time
no matter how big or small developers
might be
they usually go in and meet with
developers and they tend to make
suggestions for different business
models that they see working throughout
their app store ecosystem so what they
argued is that this is not out of the
ordinary and this was certainly not a
quid pro quo
you know this position on on ads on kind
of privacy versus personalization it
really has created this uh disparity
between how different big tech companies
sort of see the digital world where is
it leaving the relationship between
facebook and apple now
it really redefines the relationship
between the two because as these privacy
changes were coming out there was a very
sort of moral argument that was
happening with apple saying that you
know user privacy that's what matters
most that's what we're all about that's
what we're trying to protect
with these changes and facebook arguing
that we think personalized ads are what
consumers want and we think that these
type of ads help small businesses that's
how it was framed in the time
immediately after the change and in the
time right before it however now knowing
that these two companies considered
working together they certainly talked
about it there were back and forth it
really just makes you wonder
what would the digital ad industry look
like today
if perhaps they had come to some sort of
agreement that did work for
both all right that was our reporter
salvador rodriguez thanks so much for
joining us sal thank you as always
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you